in the months following the 2009
presidential election in iran
protests erupted across the country
the iranian government violently
suppressed what came to be known as the
iranian green movement
even blocking mobile signals to cut off
communication between the protesters
my parents who emigrated to the united
states in the late 1960s spend
substantial time there where
all of my large extended family live
when i would call my family in tehran
during some of the most violent
crackdown of the protest
none of them dared discuss with me what
was happening
they or i knew to quickly steer the
conversation to other topics
all of us understood what the
consequences could be
of a perceived dissident action
but i still wish i could have known what
they were thinking
or what they were
feeling what if i could have
or more frighteningly what if the
iranian government could have
would they have arrested them based on
what their brains revealed
that day may be closer than you think
with our growing capabilities in
neuroscience artificial intelligence and
machine learning
we may soon know a lot more of what's
happening in the human brain
as a bioethicist a lawyer a philosopher
and an iranian-american
i'm deeply concerned about what this
means for our freedoms and what kinds of
protections we need
i believe we need a right to cognitive
liberty
as a human right that needs to be
protected
if not our freedom of thought
access and control over our own brains
and our mental privacy will be
threatened
consider this the average person thinks
thousands of thoughts each day
as a thought takes form like a math
calculation or a number a word
neurons are interacting in the brain
creating minuscule electrical discharge
when you have a dominant mental state
like relaxation
hundreds and thousands of neurons are
firing in the brain creating concurrent
electrical discharges and characteristic
patterns that can be measured with
electroencephalography
or eeg
in fact that's what you're seeing right
now
you're seeing my brain activity that was
recorded in real time with a simple
device that was worn on my head
what you're seeing
is my brain activity when i was relaxed
and curious
to share this information with you i
wore one of the early consumer based eeg
devices like this one which recorded the
electrical activity in my brain in real
time
it's not unlike the fitness trackers
that some of you may be wearing to
measure your heart rate or the steps
that you've taken
or even your sleep activity
it's hardly the most sophisticated
neuroimaging technique on the market
but it's already the most portable and
the most likely to impact our everyday
lives
this is extraordinary through a simple
wearable device we can literally see
inside the human brain and learn aspects
of our mental landscape without ever
uttering a word
while we can't reliably decode complex
thoughts just yet
we can already gauge a person's mood
and with the help of artificial
intelligence
we can even decode some single-digit
numbers
or shapes
or simple words that a person is
thinking
or hearing or seeing
despite some inherent limitations in eeg
i think it's safe to say that with our
advances in technology
more and more of what's happening in the
human brain
can and will be decoded over time
already using one of these devices an
epileptic can know they're going to have
an epileptic seizure before it happens
a paraplegic can type on a computer with
their thoughts alone
a u.s based company has developed a
technology to embed these sensors into
the head rest of automobiles so they can
track driver concentration distraction
and cognitive load while driving
nissan
insurance companies and aaa have all
taken note
you can even watch
this choose your own adventure movie the
moment
which with an eeg headset
changes the movie based on your
brain-based reactions giving you a
different ending
every time your attention wanes
this may all sound great
and as a bioethicist i am a huge
proponent
of empowering people to take charge of
their own health and well-being by
giving them access to information about
themselves including this incredible new
brain decoding technology
but i worry
i worry that we will voluntarily or
involuntarily
give up our last bastion of freedom
our mental privacy
that we will trade our brain activity
for rebates or discounts on insurance
or free access to social media accounts
or even to keep our jobs
in fact in china
the
train drivers on the
beijing shanghai high-speed rail the
busiest of its kind in the world
are required to wear eeg devices to
monitor their brain activity while
driving
according to some news sources
in government run factories in china the
workers are required to wear eeg sensors
to monitor their productivity
and their emotional state at work
workers are even sent home
if their brains show less than stellar
concentration on their jobs
or emotional agitation
it's not going to happen tomorrow but
we're headed to a world of brain
transparency and i don't think people
understand that that could change
everything
everything from our definitions of data
privacy to our laws to our ideas about
freedom
in fact
in my lab at duke university we recently
conducted a nationwide study in the
united states to see if people
appreciated the sensitivity of their
brain information
we ask people to rate their perceived
sensitivity of 33 different kinds of
information
from their social security numbers to
the content of their phone conversations
their relationship history
their emotions their anxiety the mental
images in their minds and the thoughts
in their mind
shockingly
people rated their social security
number as far more sensitive than any
other kind of information including
their brain data
i think this is because people don't yet
understand or believe
the implications of this new brain
decoding technology
after all if we can know the inner
workings of the human brain our social
security numbers are the least of our
worries
think about it in a world of total brain
transparency who would dare have a
politically dissident thought
or a creative one
i worry that people will some
self-censor
in fear of being ostracized by society
or that people will lose their jobs
because of their waning attention or
emotional instability
or because they're contemplating
collective action against their
employers
that coming out will no longer be an
option because people's brains will long
ago have revealed their sexual
orientation their political ideology or
their religious preferences
well before they were ready to
consciously share that information with
other people
i worry about the ability of our laws to
keep up with technological change
take the first amendment of the u.s
constitution which protects freedom of
speech
does it also protect freedom of thought
and if so does that mean that we're free
to alter our thoughts however we want or
can the government or society tell us
what we can do with our own brains
can the nsa spy on our brains using
these new mobile devices
can the companies that collect the brain
data through their applications sell
this information to third parties
right now no laws prevent them from
doing so
it could be even more problematic in
countries that don't share the same
freedoms enjoyed by people in the united
states
what would have happened during the
iranian green movement
if the government had been monitoring my
family's brain activity and had believed
them to be sympathetic to the protesters
is it so far-fetched to imagine a
society in which people are arrested
based on their thoughts of committing a
crime like in the science fiction
dystopian society minority report
already in the united states
in indiana an 18 year old was charged
with attempting to intimidate his school
by posting a video of himself shooting
people in the hallways
except the people
were zombies
and the video was of him playing an
augmented reality video game all
interpreted to be a mental projection
of his subjective intent
this is exactly why our brains need
special protection
if our brains are just a subject to data
tracking and aggregation is our
financial records and transactions if
our brains can be hacked and tracked
like our online activities our mobile
phones and applications then we're on
the brink of a dangerous threat to our
collective humanity
before you panic
i believe that there are solutions to
these concerns
but we have to start by focusing on the
right things
when it comes to privacy protections in
general
i think we're fighting a losing battle
by trying to restrict the flow of
information
instead we should be focusing on
securing rights and remedies against the
misuse of our information
if people had the right to decide how
their information was shared and more
importantly had legal redress
if their information was misused against
them say to discriminate against them in
an employment setting or in healthcare
or in education
this would go a long way to build trust
in fact in some instances we want to be
sharing more of our personal information
studying aggregated information can tell
us so much about our health and our
well-being
but to be able to safely share our
information
we need special protections for mental
privacy
this is why we need a right to cognitive
liberty
this right would secure for us our
freedom of thought and rumination
our freedom of self-determination
and it would ensure that we have the
right to consent to or refuse
access and alteration of our brains by
others this right could be recognized as
part of the universal declaration of
human rights which has established
mechanisms for the enforcement of these
kinds of social rights
during the iranian green movement the
protesters used the internet
and good old-fashioned word of mouth to
coordinate their marches
and some of the most oppressive
restrictions in iran were lifted as a
result
but what if the iranian government
had used brain surveillance to detect
and prevent the protest
would the world have ever heard the
protesters cries
the time has come for us to call for a
cognitive liberty revolution
to make sure that we responsibly advance
technology that could enable us to
embrace the future
while fiercely protecting all of us
from any person company or government
that attempts to unlawfully access or
alter our innermost lives
thank you
[Applause]